now the New York Times has obtained
leaked Chinese government documents that
it says reveal new details about
Beijing's crackdown on Muslim wiggers in
this shinjang region around a million
wiggers are believed to be entered and
what the Chinese call vocational
training centers intended to re-educate
people leaning towards extremism
now the documents include instructions
to local authorities on how to handle
students returning home and finding
family members detained or missing how
to control wiggers and plans to extend
restrictions on Islam to other parts of
China and the documents reveal how the
crackdown worsened after a hard-line
local polity local party chief rather
took control of Xinjiang in 2016 the
league also suggests that there's
resistance within the Communist Party
against the crackdown well let's get
more on this now we're joined by Sophie
Richardson the China director at Human
Rights Watch and she's joining us live
from Washington DC very good to have you
with us on al-jazeera today it is an
extraordinary league when you go through
the documents you know we've long heard
about what's happening at these camps in
Xinjiang at least in part thanks to
organizations like yourselves but have
we ever seen the scale or you know how
methodical it is you know I think these
these documents are extraordinary in two
ways not just as you say for the details
that they provide but that they clearly
show the culpability from Xi Jinping all
the way down through local officials in
imposing these policies and of course as
you've just mentioned it seems that some
people resisted that but but as a legal
matter it's now incredibly clear who's
responsible for these highly abusive
policies at the same time one reads this
story and thinks about all of the people
in the Uighur diaspora worldwide who are
reading the same information and really
having their worst fears about what's
happened to their family members
confirmed and that that must just be an
excruciating reality for them and I
think increases the pressure for titles
to be held accountable absolutely as you
mentioned you know this must be so
distressing for the many we go
in the diaspora we have heard from a lot
of them on al Jazeera could this report
change things for them for their
families in the camps though I certainly
think it brings that much more pressure
to there particularly on member states
of the United Nations to push for an
independent fact-finding mission to the
region ideally under the auspices of the
High Commissioner for Human Rights you
know and for any of the governments that
have resisted the idea that Chinese
authorities are actually carrying out
this campaign of repression you know the
facade of support for China's position
really is starting to crumble and this
report goes a long way towards you know
denying people the ability to say well
it's not really happening or there's no
credible evidence here it is and how you
know much more important is it to do
this now because the report goes into
plans you know to extend restrictions on
Muslims around the country on other
minorities too well we think it's been
urging to mount that kind of
investigation for well over a year now
and I think every day that goes by
without holding China accountable
reinforces an extraordinary kind of
impunity and if anybody thinks that
those abuses are gonna stay within
China's borders we've got news for you
they're not and that's why China really
needs to come under pressure right now
to play by the same rules as every other
government in the world is expected to
and we've seen you know that the
government hasn't responded to
international pressure at all so far
they have let a few people into these
camps into these areas but they have
been so heavily monitored and their
movement restricted no it's a it is
certainly a tall order but let's imagine
for a moment that any other government
in the world was arbitrarily detaining a
million Muslims let's imagine if the US
was doing that or you know Germany or
Japan or a country in the Gulf for
example I think we would see a very
different response and international law
and established practice is very clear
that the deployment of an
independent fact-finding mission that
can make a determination about how the
international community should then
respond is a well-established practice I
mean look at what's happening with
respect to the gross violations of wrote
INGOs rights in Myanmar now or what's
happened with North Korea you know this
is how the world is meant to respond in
the face of gross human rights
violations and I think it is especially
important to do so with a state as
powerful inside and outside the UN
system as China miss Richardson we thank
you very much for your time on this
today we do appreciate it that is Sophia
Richardson live in Washington DC thank
you